[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola bienvenidos a corresponsable soy
santiago lópez gonzález por mi compañero
andrés espinal mientras las fuerzas
rusas libran una ardua batalla para
tomar la región del donbass quien
reforzó sus posiciones en otras regiones
del país una situación que se puede
evidenciar claramente en el norte de
gerzón una ciudad capturada por rusia
desde el comienzo de la invasión aunque
el ejército ucraniano ha recuperado algo
de terreno sigue teniendo una gran
carencia de armamento moderno para poder
hacer frente al ataque enemigo un grupo
de reporteros de nuestra cadena hermana
france24 en inglés se desplazaron hasta
el frente de batalla en esa región
hasta hace unas semanas la posición de
este regimiento ucraniano estaba en
primera línea los rusos están ahora a 6
km de distancia al concentrar sus
esfuerzos en la región del donbass a
veces han permitido a kiev recuperar
terreno en otros lugares como aquí en el
norte gerson y poco a poco
note que la mayor parte del tiempo solo
defendemos nuestras posiciones pero en
algunos lugares contra atacamos esta
mañana nuestra fuerza aérea bombardeó
posiciones enemigas
el ejército ucraniano ha retomado
algunas posiciones clave en la zona pero
un contraataque mayor aún no está en la
agenda
por ahora la meta es impedir una nueva
entrega de armas rusas pero esta unidad
del ejército regular tiene poco
armamento construido para ese objetivo
como lo muestra esta pieza de artillería
de la época soviética
necesitamos cañones ms 777 que pueden
disparar hasta 30 kilómetros de
distancia y esta arma antitanque solo lo
podemos usar una vez
pero el javelin puede recargarse
continuamente con nuevos misiles
las entregas de armas occidentales aún
no han tenido efecto importante en el
frente el ejército ucraniano carece de
artillería moderna y lanzadores de
misiles ante ataque de última generación
como éste ya belín americano este joven
soldado dice que ha podido hacer buen
uso de la eficacia del arma
gates foundation no sólo instructora en
fui entrenado en la región de quien
fuera un instructor americano
información duró dos semanas en la
región de lugares destruimos unos 20
objetivos con esto
nos faltan armas como esta para cubrir
todas nuestras posiciones en el frente
los oficiales ucranianos han dicho en
repetidas ocasiones que el suministro de
armas modernas podría cambiar el curso
de la guerra
los efectos de la guerra en ucrania y el
bloqueo del comercio con rusia comienzan
a sentirse en el sector agroalimentario
en italia rusia y ucrania proveen
conjuntamente 28 por ciento de las
exportaciones mundiales de trigo también
el 29 por ciento de la cebada a nivel
mundial y el 15 por ciento del maíz la
guerra ha golpeado severamente esta
producción millones de toneladas de
cereales están bloqueadas en ucrania y
rusia porque los puertos tanto del mar
negro como del mar de azov están
cerrados en italia el impacto de esta
crisis en el intercambio internacional
de estos cereales ya lo sienten los
agricultores los importadores y por
supuesto los consumidores natalia
mendoza nuestra corresponsal en italia
nos cuenta más
desde hace más de 50 años la familia de
domenico carone cultiva trigo en este
terreno de 70 hectáreas en apulia la
principal región italiana productora de
cereales un cultivo cuyos costos se han
disparado desde el inicio de la guerra
en ucrania el costo del fertilizante el
precio de los fertilizantes se ha
triplicado porque la mayor parte de los
fertilizantes que usamos aquí en italia
viene de los países en guerra el
conflicto de esta mañana con un
sindicato agrícola domenico analiza un
posible aumento de su superficie de
cultivo
la región quiere cultivar 100 mil
hectáreas suplementarias de trigo para
prevenir la escasez de cereales debido
al bloqueo de las importaciones de rusia
y ucrania si producimos más trigo aquí
en italia podríamos liberarnos de la
dependencia de otros países hay que
cultivar más aquí se trata de una
estrategia nacional que busca la
autosuficiencia y la soberanía
alimentaria soberanía alimentaria un
objetivo ambicioso actualmente y está le
importa más del 30 por ciento del trigo
que consume en forma de pan galletas
el plato nacional los productores de
pasta que usan trigo italiano también se
ven afectados como esta empresa familiar
de pasta artesanal como ya no llegan
cereales de ucrania los productores que
usaban esas harinas ahora todos buscan
harinas italianas y el mercado interno
no da abasto para cubrir toda esta
demanda
haciendo una venta al detalle nos vemos
obligados a trasladar parte de los
aumentos en el precio final al
consumidor y paralelamente reducir
nuestros márgenes de ganancia el
gobierno espera en los próximos meses
aumentar las importaciones de cereales
de países como canadá o grecia para
evitar que estalle una crisis
alimentaria en italia
según datos oficiales del año 2021 en
israel fueron denunciados más de 2 mil
900 ataques contra integrantes de la
comunidad lgtb de más si las
discriminaciones ya todo un problema en
el territorio israelí en jerusalén oeste
choca con una sociedad que es muy
conservadora y además muy religiosa las
personas del colectivo el gti con más
sufren tanto agresiones verbales como
físicas también amenazas incluso hay que
más de las banderas de este colectivo
sin embargo esta comunidad que es
pequeña pero unida defiende su lugar en
esta ciudad y lucha por alcanzar la
igualdad el informes de nuestros
corresponsales yanira gómez muñoz y
federico cue barberena
organizamos una manifestación aquí mismo
y un chico empezó a ser más y más
agresivo a decir cosas homofóbicas
cuando se sintió realmente frustrado
comenzó a maldecir nos y me escupió en
los pies smurfit
cada tres horas se denuncian en israel-
agresiones como la que sufrió nada un
caso de lg bético fobia que en jerusalén
oeste se agudiza por el conservadurismo
y la multiplicidad de religiones
caminar de la mano no es tan fácil a
veces recibes gritos o te maldicen te
miran
tengo amigos a los que les han quitado o
quemado banderas de sus balcones a mí y
a otros nos han rechazado el alquiler de
casas porque nos presentamos como
homosexuales gay
la violencia no vence a nada siendo
judío y gay defiende férreamente
jerusalén como el mejor lugar en el
canal su fe y su identidad
hay gente que dice que está en contra
por motivos religiosos y no creo que sea
por eso creo que es por razones
históricas o de sociedades porque el
judaísmo en sí cree en la aceptación
exacta
pero cuál sea el pronombre o creencia la
mayor aceptación se da en la jerusalem
open house fundada en 1997 y ante el
desamparo del gobierno local a esta casa
abierta acuden cada año 30 mil personas
en busca de ayuda sanitaria educativa y
emocional
la violencia es real aquí en jerusalén
específicamente contra la comunidad lgbt
pumas empieza con micro agresiones
pequeñas y vastas incidentes después
está el hecho de que la municipalidad de
jerusalén no apoya realmente a nuestra
comunidad
si su marcha del orgullo existe desde
hace 20 años es mérito de la comunidad
en el desfile nada brinda información e
insignias y se moviliza con su grupo
religioso
todo ocurre bajo custodia policial y
militar luego de que en 2015 un judío
ultraortodoxo asesinar a la adolescente
syrah banking la violencia es un desafío
en esta ciudad muchas personas no nos
aceptan por motivos religiosos pero veo
que cada año va mejorando cada vez más
a jerusalén aún le queda un largo camino
para hacer de la igualdad diversidad
también la palestina una norma en tierra
santa
la reina isabel segunda es probablemente
y sin proponérselo la mujer más famosa
del mundo ha sido fotografiada millones
de veces pero también ha sido retratada
miles de veces a lo largo de sus más de
90 años de vida
las celebraciones multitudinarias para
conmemorar sus 70 años en el trono de la
casa de windsor tampoco fueron la
excepción nuestra corresponsal en
londres louis ha pulido nos presenta
algunos de los artistas que han
retratado y pintado a la monarca
y sandías
la primera vez que jeffs tool tienes vio
a la reina isabel tiene 8 años la salud
en la calle mientras ondeaba la bandera
británica el día de la coronación de la
monarca el segundo encuentro fue más
cercano poso para él mientras le hacía
el retrato que hoy descubre el oro el
college de la universidad de oxford
pensé que no era permitido darle la mano
a la reina
y extendió su mano y dije perdón señora
pero he estado limpiando la paleta para
estar aquí probablemente me manche las
manos con pintura y ella dijo oh no
importa esta mañana estaba usando mi
pluma y la pluma explotó probablemente
manche las mías con tinta esta era su
manera de decir que está bien online
en seis sesiones privadas y largas
conversaciones
isabel dejó ver sus conocimientos de
arte y su perspicacia
y afuera del palacio los guardias
marchan arriba y abajo la banda está
tocando ella me miró por la ventana y
dijo esa es una nota equivocada
ayer le tomo 40 horas perfeccionar el
estilo y color de pelo de la reina y
seis meses terminar el cuadro pero en
segundos descubrió la verdadera y sabe
si ella ha conocido a todos los primeros
ministros a todos los presidentes a
nivel internacional desde los años
cincuenta
es una opinión similar tiene chris
jackson quien ha sido el fotógrafo de la
reina por 20 años después de acompañar
las recorridos por el mundo o
fotografiar la en el día a día jackson
sabe que escocia es uno de sus lugares
favoritos y obviamente tiene un gran
sentido del humor le encanta cuando está
con su familia si realmente la ves
perilla especialmente con sus nietos
crisis la ha fotografiado exclusivamente
en cuatro oportunidades pero él ha
tomado millones de fotos escribir es
despeja es esta persona a la que la
gente admira que ha estado ahí durante
toda nuestra vida en el entorno con 96
años y saber seguirá siendo un icono y
fotografiada en cada aparición pública
no sólo por profesionales sino por
millones de personas
es todo por hoy en corresponsales muchas
gracias por su sintonía queremos
agradecer a café lamata por habernos
prestado sus instalaciones para nuestra
grabación el día de hoy nosotros nos
volvemos a encontrar en una próxima
oportunidad hasta pronto